Here's a very simple app that
has a map embedded within it.
It doesn't have visual controls along
the map that allow me to do things such
as zoom in and out.
But I can actually pinch
the map if I want to zoom.
Here you can see I'm zooming in, and
here you can see I'm zooming out.
It also has data such as country names,
you can see here the United States
country name as well as the states
in the United States and cities.
And also here we can see
Mexico is a country name.
So a lot of the data is already
available on this map for me and
I'll show shortly how I built this and
it was very, very simple,
very straightforward, and effectively
getting all of this data for free.
If I zoom in on a specific location,
like right now I'm going to zoom in
on the Silicon Valley area, and
we begin to see town names.
And if I get in even closer
we'll begin to see street names.
Here you can see West El Camino Real.
We can see Latham Street.
This is right here where I'm recording,
and
if I zoom even closer we'll begin
to see individual buildings.
And here we can see buildings appearing.
Across the road from
here is a shopping mall.
And, actually some building when,
I zoom right into them,
I begin to see some of the details
of the interior of the building.
So here we can see I have a department
store very close to me, and
I'm beginning to see the sections within
the department store Including the fact
that they put the bakery right
beside the intimate apparel.
Now, all of this data came with the maps
without me having to write anything.
I just added the map to an Android
app with a default customization.
It's very, very simple to do.
And in the next few minutes, you're
actually going to build this exact app,
and it will give you the foundation for
building much more complex and
interesting mapping apps
later in this course.
So let's get started.